I want to get to Julie Hyman for some
breaking news on Carl Icahn he's a very
active and putting some money together
to fight what he feels are certain and
justices yeah getting involved in
politics here he is going to be forming
a super PAC with an initial commitment
of 150 million dollars icon says it's a
no-brainer for Congress to pass a
highway bill as well but he's basically
released a letter that says a lot of
different where he's making a lot of
different political comments he says the
back though is going to focus on the
effects of corporate tax inversions
that's really going to be the target of
it he said he's concerned of her
corporate tax inversions and companies
leaving the United States he does plan
to raise a third party funds as well
other comments he's making the Fed has
already kept rates too low for too long
and scarlet when he talks about this you
know it's interesting when you first see
the super PAC headline my assumption was
that it would be in some way to support
Donald Trump because he has talked about
his endorsement Trump of course has
talked about the need to keep companies
and keep money and keep workers in the
United States so this would seem to be
in line with some of trumps campaign
platform yes but instead it has to do
with stopping corporate tax inversions
and stopping companies from leaving the
u.s. Carl Icahn also making some
comments here about the US economy being
very fragile and fed napping in a
position to to do much to add system
yeah